[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zu einer neuen folge führte nach
acht wir werden heute abend über die
news geschichten debattieren die
deutschland bewegen und emotionalisieren
sei es karl lauterbach nächtlicher tweet
das ampel corona chaos
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach
selbst die entschuldigung von
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
und die flüchtlingssituation wie das
alles in eine sendung passt er das
erklärt den besonderen zauber von
viertel nach acht meine großartigen
gäste heute abend sind die frühere
staatsministerin für digitalisierung und
bundestagsabgeordneten dorothee bär die
österreichische politik kommentator
heimo lepuschitz bild politik redakteur
sebastian geisler und der
cdu-bundestagsabgeordnete und
gymnasiallehrer johannes steiniger uns
alle verbindet die freude am debattieren
wie wahrscheinlich auch sie zu hause
sonst hätten sie ja gar nicht
eingeschaltet und ich möchte heute abend
den anfang machen seit monaten
beschäftigt mich die einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht stammzuschauer
werden das wissen sie spricht für mich
ging jede ethik und jede moral die mich
mein elternhaus lehrte er ist heute
lasse ich die uni klinik bonn meldet
jetzt noch 800 mitarbeiter ans
gesundheitsamt der grund seit mehr als
zwei wochen geht jetzt diese impfpflicht
im gesundheitswesen in bayern bekommen
menschen die sich gegen die krone
impfung entschieden haben nun auch post
vom gesundheitsamt sich beraten zu
lassen ich finde die einrichtungs
bezogen impfpflicht falsch und während
morgen im bundestag über eine mögliche
impfpflicht entschieden wird ist wird
also die das finale seine impfpflicht
debatte über die 18 wurde ja schon
entschieden die kommen nicht finde ich
dass wir an diesem abend vor dem
morgigen die partie nicht vergessen
sollten dass wir schon längst eine
impfpflicht haben und das ist die
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht also
da bin ich tatsächlich völlig andere
meinung als du weißt ich bin von der
allgemeine impfpflicht tatsächlich kein
fan aber wenn es irgendwo eine
impfpflicht gibt die man sinnvollerweise
haben sollten unser mann dann in
bestimmten einrichtungen gerade in
krankenhäusern warum weil zum beispiel
krankenpfleger krankenschwestern weil
die ihre sozusagen ihre ihre
schutzbefohlenen haben das sind die
menschen die sich dort notgedrungene
weise aufhalten das gleiche geht in dem
pflegeheim deswegen wenn irgendwo im
pflicht dann dort und du bist jetzt hier
sehr große worte gleich zu anfang ich
glaube das ist durchaus rational
vertretbar und begründbar dort in
solchen einrichtungen pflichten zu haben
also krankenschwestern physiotherapeutin
ist klingt ja auch für medizin studenten
für studenten der zahnmedizin das sind
ja alles bereiche denen die einrichtungs
bezogen impfpflicht fallen ich halte das
auch aus einem anderen grund noch für
falsch dass gerade die krankenhäuser
auch angesprochen ms hat letztens auch
ich glaube ich hab's im fokus gelesen
hat eine krankenschwester in auch dafür
plädiert ich meine es bei der focus das
heißt die pfleger auch arbeiten kommen
dürfen die nicht geimpft sind wir haben
in der pflege schon wenig personal die
menschen haben sich zwei jahre für
dieses land aufgeopfert auch viele und
ich finde ich denke immer darüber nach
was ist wenn die gesellschaft mal etwas
von mir fordert wer sich nicht bereit
bin zu geben was ist dann und mein
hauptargument aber dann eröffnen wir
auch mal die runde sonst wird der
monolog mein hauptargument gegen die
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht ist
dass man sich ja auch anstecken kann
also wenn es und da glaube sogar ich
wäre ich vielleicht sogar für die
allgemeine impfpflicht gewesen wenn man
sich nicht dann mehr anstecken kann und
es sozusagen zu einer ausrottung führen
würde von corona dann wäre ich auch für
die einrichtungs bezogen pflicht das ist
aber nicht der fall aber wie sehen sie
das herr steininger also gebt gebt ihnen
absolut recht wir haben uns ja auch als
union sehr schwer getan als wir im
dezember der einrichtungs bezogen
impfpflicht zugestimmt haben damals ja
aber noch in der in der diskussion dass
es eventuell eine allgemeine impfpflicht
gibt und man dann in diesem wichtigen
bereich voran geht und gleichzeitig
sehen wir jetzt am eigentlich ist es
derzeit einen papiertiger die landkreise
sollen das ganze überprüfen sind dazu
auch gar nicht in der lage ich
persönlich kenne keinen einzigen
bußgeldbescheid der erstellt worden ist
wir haben keine betretungsverbote und am
schluss eine regelung die nicht
kontrolliert wird und die nichts bringt
da muss man schon darüber sprechen ob
man die nicht dann aussetzt insbesondere
wenn wir morgen dafür sorgen dass es
keine impfpflicht geben wird ja aber das
ist ja wirklich spannend wenn man sich
ansieht wie sich jetzt die politik
sondern von dem verabschiedet was ich
selber mit beschlossen hat das ist das
sehr spannend auch als opposition dass
wir jetzt nicht mehr daran erinnern
können was sie eigentlich mit
beschlossen haben und man muss ja fragen
wie gehen denn mit dieser impfpflicht um
ja jahrelang haben wir gehört dass sind
die helden der krise ein pfleger dies
stehen an der vordersten front und jetzt
gibt es in europa weit berufsverbote für
menschen die wir vorher noch als helden
gefeiert haben keine einzige begründung
mehr wenn man sich durch ließ die
begründung das deutsche
gesundheitsministeriums warum es denn
diese endlich geben muss dann steht da
drinnen weil corona eine höchst
gefährliche tödliche infektionskrankheit
ist so jetzt ist aber omikron
ungefährlicher wie die grippe also nach
dieser logik bräuchten wir eine
impfpflicht für die krippe weil die
grippe gefährlicher die omikron sagen
alle zahlen bloß es ist natürlich
es gibt keinen unterschied bei der
ansteckung zwischen geimpften und
ungeimpften also sie können ungeimpft
oder geimpft im alter seien genauso
jemanden anstecken wie sonst also es
gibt auch keine logische begründung es
ist einfach nur eine politik die
mittlerweile nicht mehr nach vorne und
nach hinten weiß und nicht ein sich
eingestehen kann ich habe mich geirrt
hier würde ich gerne frau bär reinholen
kann man das so sagen ungefährlicher als
die grippe also ich finde solche
aussagen immer sehr gefährlich weil es
natürlich sehr unterschiedlich ist wie
es bei den menschen ankommt es gibt eben
diejenigen und ich habe wirklich schon
alles gesehen die tatsächlich nichts
hatten jetzt auch bei mikron aber auch
welche die wirklich sehr sehr stark
gelitten haben viel viel stärker als man
das bei einer grippe machen würde und
was natürlich nicht stimmt was sie
gerade behauptet haben dass man sich an
dinge nicht mehr erinnert die man im
letzten jahr abgestimmt hat das hat
jetzt so steininger ja auch gesagt das
war eine andere ausgangssituation
die ampel hat er auch ich sage jetzt
noch lose kabel
ist die vorstufe dann auch zu einer
allgemeinen impfpflicht bund die
vorbereitungen wurden ja teilweise auch
noch bei delta getroffen das heißt man
muss natürlich sagen dass omikron jetzt
eine andere variante ist die weniger
gefährlich ist ja aber die natürlich
trotzdem waren jetzt sich so entwickelt
hat dass wir eben sagen auch als cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion wir brauchen jetzt
keine allgemeine impfpflicht weil es
eben nicht in der verhältnismäßigkeit
steht und jetzt macht die ampel tricks
an dieser stelle schon alleine mücken
abstimmungsmodus jetzt versuchen sie
halt tatsächlich noch was durchzudrücken
ich hab auch ich habe in bayern abitur
gemacht hat nicht gelernt dass 18 plus
50 60 ist aber so scheint es anscheinend
jetzt auch bei der ampel zu sein das ist
ein totales chaos die regierung hat
überhaupt keinen gemeinsamen entwurf
vorgelegt also die einzigen die wirklich
stringent einen entwurf der auch ein ins
register vorsieht vorliegt das sind wir
und ohne im register braucht man sowas
überhaupt nicht anzufangen besteht da
muss ich mich ihnen anschließen die
cdu/csu haben ihre position natürlich
gewechselt ist vernünftig wo man eher
kritisieren muss ist ja da mehrheits
steigbügelhalter der regierung das ist
die fdp die ja mittlerweile einfach die
bordsteinschwalben von rot grün ist als
innerlich kommerz am von golding
vielleicht nicht aber inhaltlich würde
ich das hier schreibe von rot-grün
sebastian als politikredakteur von bett
gehst du damit auch das ist mir das ist
mir eins drüber würde ich sagen die
ampel hat schon irgendwie auch ein
bisschen zusammengefunden jetzt dass das
das schreibt für das scheint mir schon
wäre falls es einen gäbe ja ja ja gute
dass manche umstimmigkeiten er
möglicherweise dass das kann schon sein
aber ich glaube das interessante bei
dieser diskussion ist er kenne durchaus
diese gegenargumente an die jetzt gerade
ins ins feld geführt wo er und sagen
trotzdem dafür für die einrichtungs
beziehung ich würde sagen alles was das
hilft gegen krohne ist immer erst mal
gut und gerade wenn menschen dort hat
sich mein vater lebt auch im pflegeheim
zum beispiel wo ich dann am anfang
fragte wieso ist denn jetzt schon wieder
zu bei ihnen hieß es ja wir haben hier
kroner fälle und so weiter nämlich mehr
menschen sind doch jetzt aber alle
durchgehend schnee sind ja gar nicht
alle geimpft wieso sind nicht alle gm
sprechen ja manche alten wollen das
nicht okay muss man akzeptieren
akzeptiere ich aber dann auch selbst
pfleger teilweise und da muss ich sagen
da habe ich dann schon irgendwie sehr
seltsames gefühl aber das finde ich wenn
das dazu hilft und ich habe zum beispiel
wie russland zu reduzieren sondern sich
auch impfen im dienste der menschen für
die diese menschen dort ja eigentlich
tätig sind und man muss natürlich auch
sagen also wir erwarten natürlich also
ich erwarte von jeder pflegerin von
jedem pfleger dass er oder sie sich
impfen lässt weil wenn man im
gesundheitsbereich arbeitet dann auch
mit höchst wunderwaffen gruppen dann
erwarte ich das schon
gleichzeitig ist natürlich eine pflicht
einzuführen sehr großer eingriff auch
ins grundrecht und wir haben das ganze
im dezember beschlossen da gibt es auch
noch ein anderes gesetz mit den anderen
maßnahmen wurde es dann geworden ist
aber damals haben wir tatsächlich bei
delta gesprochen und das war noch mal
eine ganz andere nummer jetzt unter
omikron sehen wir dass an der stelle
nicht und deswegen muss man aus meiner
sicht auch darüber sprechen ob man die
jetzt nicht aussetzt aber wir mussten
sie müssen sie aber wirklich aufpassen
weil stellen sie sich vor ich weiß nur
von österreich in österreich in ungefähr
20 prozent des pflegepersonals nicht
geimpft bei den ärzten zehn prozent
jetzt verzichten wir jetzt bei omikron
wo es sehr viele menschen noch infiziert
mobile im krankenstand sind aufgrund
dieser absolut dämlichen quarantäne
verzichten wir würden wir verzichten auf
20 prozent des pflegepersonals und
jammern dass wir viel zu wenig personal
haben anstatt dass wir das personal
ausbauen in den jahren der korona
epidemie die pflegebetten erweitern dass
wir das gesundheitssystem
anpassen die jeder vernünftige
unternehmer das machen würde ja man geht
auch darüber dass wir viel zu wenig
pflegepersonal haben wir müssen halt die
leute gescheit zahlen wir müssen die
leute ausbilden und das dauert jahre und
jahre lang ist nichts getan worden und
jetzt sagen wir der verzicht einfach so
oder so wie offenbar tausend menschen
die leben retten stellen sie sich vor
sie liegen im altersheim und es kommt
niemand und das sage ich in der pflege
steht vor der tür und sagt ich würde
ihnen gerne helfen aber ich bin geimpft
wir können ja auch noch mal weitergehen
das thema krankenhaus und pflegeheim
sind ja auch immer die sehr emotionalen
punkte mit denen man sich beschäftigt
aber zu der einrichtungs beziehungen
impfpflicht warum es mich auch so sehr
stört mich stolz aber auch bei pfleger
nicht und auch da dagegen auch mehr
krankenschwester ich bin dafür ist jeder
frei wer seinen körper entscheidet auch
mit blick auf die wohnanlage aber was
ich eigentlich sagen will ist wenn zum
beispiel mein physiotherapeut der hat
jetzt aufgehört der kann mich jetzt auch
nicht mehr behandeln weil er hat sich
gegen die impfung entschieden hat dann
so ein schreiben geschickt er hat jetzt
auf mit seiner praxis und so weiter und
da hab ich mir dann die frage gestellt
wie würde ich auch gerne an frau bär
geben weil ich mich die auch so oft in
der politik gefragt habe mein
physiotherapeut und ich sind ja
eigentlich zwei erwachsene menschen und
wenn ich entscheide ich finde das völlig
in ordnung ich arbeite ja auch mit
menschen die sich nicht gegen die grippe
beispielsweise impfen gelassen haben
warum darf dann eigentlich eher nicht
mehr mit mir trainieren
wie konnte das denn eigentlich passieren
dass die politik auf solche
entscheidungen für mich trifft und damit
auf dem physiotherapeuten ja gut er
arbeitet natürlich nicht nur mit ihnen
sondern er arbeitet natürlich mit vielen
anderen patienten und mein physio
therapeuten zum beispiel der ist total
dagegen also der ist gm das ganze team
ist geimpft und der sagt auch er wird
nie auch wenn die masten mal abgeschafft
sind werde sie trotzdem nicht ablegen er
und sein ganzes team bleiben auch bei ft
zwei masken weil er zum beispiel sehr
viele krebspatienten hat und weil er
einfach möchte dass gerade diese wollen
gruppen die auch zu ihm kommen und die
kommen
wo es sie und er vorher alleine waren
natürlich wird desinfiziert aber er sagt
er hat eine ganz große fürsorgepflicht
weil die krebspatienten in zum beispiel
angerufen haben und gesagt haben wenn er
nicht die höchsten schutzmaßnahme griff
dann kommen die nicht mehr und ich
glaube es geht nicht immer nur um einen
selber sondern das geht eben auch um
viele andere die man da zu schützen hat
die frage ist natürlich klar bei den
berufen wo fängt man wo wird man auf wo
sind ganz besonders wohl nahe gruppen
kann man auch über ich hab heute eine
zuschrift bekommen von der
krankenschwester aus meinem wahlkreis
die angesagt bevor der bundes für uns
ein führt soll das mal für alle
staatsbeamte einführen das war ihr
vorschlag das erstmal der stadt mit
gutem beispiel vorangehe halt ich's
vergesse ich eigentlich auch keine
schlechte idee also ich glaube man muss
halt in der demokratie dann auch mal
diskutieren wir haben in den letzten
jahren im vorletzten jahr ja schon seit
zwei jahren das sehr viel tun müssen was
man vorher so nicht kannte man hat ja
auch keine blaupause so eine pandemie
gab es eben vorher noch nicht wo man
sich drauf zurückziehen konnte da wurden
sicherlich auch nicht alles richtig
gemacht in den letzten zwei jahren aber
ich kann schon sagen auf jeden fall für
die große mehrheit unserer kolleginnen
und kollegen dass man wirklich immer
auch in der aktuellen lage anpassung das
nach bestem wissen und gewissen gemacht
hat nur momentan sehe ich das nicht weil
ich schon sehen und da bin ich anderer
meinung als sie das ich schon glaube
dass aus vielen parteitaktischen und
parteipolitischen spielchen jetzt in der
aktuellen ampel weil man eben nicht
zusammen gerauft ist weil es nämlich
wirklich kraft ohne ende an jeder stelle
an jeder ecke weil sie überhaupt nicht
zusammenpassen weil es nur ums reine
regieren geht dass wir morgen großes
abstimmungs und große fehler erleben
werden und da denkt man wirklich offenen
auges rein und damit das war ein
wunderbarer übergangsrat hat sich dank
da kommen wir zu ihrem thema heute abend
was die uns mitgebracht haben steinig ja
deutschland steckt im ampel corona chaos
wir haben gerade eben schon über die
impfpflicht diskutiert aus meiner sicht
ist sie gescheitert olaf scholz der
bundeskanzlerin wollte sie haben aber
ich sage ihnen voraus dass morgen keine
mehrheit für einen der anträge da sein
wird und jetzt geht es nur noch um
gesichtswahrung wir sehen dass tricks
angewandt werden im verfahren jetzt
werden kompromisse vorgelegt aus der
impfpflicht 18 und der impfpflicht 50
wird die impfpflicht 60 dabei sind in
dieser altersgruppe mehr als 90 prozent
auch schon geimpft und
ich sage ihnen das ganze führt zu
politikverdrossenheit wir haben bürger
gestern schon geschrieben hört auf mit
diesen partei spielchen und deswegen
können wir als union nur die ampel dazu
auffordern stimmen sie unserem antrag zu
der derzeit unter omikron keine
impfpflicht vorsieht aber die
notwendigen voraussetzungen dafür stellt
das falls die umstände wieder anders
sind dass man durchaus eine pflicht
einführen kann ja ich möchte es noch mal
unterstreichen weil es wirklich kann es
von außen ja oft gar nicht so beurteilen
aber es wird ja dann auch immer versucht
so auf uns zuzugehen ja und er rettet
uns doch so nach dem motto und das finde
ich schon spannend wenn dann immer so
die kolleginnen und kollegen auch sagen
wir vergleichen sie jetzt mal um es
höflich auszudrücken denn der
amtierenden regierung und noch nie gab
es einen so schlechten start bei einer
bundesregierung wie bei dieser und jetzt
werde union vorgeworfen wenn wir ihnen
nicht den hintern treten bei einer sache
die offensichtlich falsch ist dann wird
uns die schuld in die schuhe geschoben
und das ist mit uns nicht zu machen weil
wir wollen wirklich jetzt auch aus einer
verantwortungsvollen position heraus das
richtige tun und das machen wir mit
unserem antrag gehen übrigens auch viele
in der aktuellen regierung gut fänden
sich aber nicht trauen dazu zustimmen
frau bär die einigkeit heute die man
zwischen ihnen beiden erlebt cdu und csu
die hat man ja im wahlkampf vermisst
also genau das was gerade passiert ist
diese traute bei sagen sie hätten ja
vielleicht auch wehren können wenn das
genauso gut schon vorher geklappt hätte
ich sag mal so wir hatten heute einige
rednerinnen der spd am pult und dann hat
ein kollege den ich nicht mehr nennen
möchte hat also von hinten rein gerufen
und gegen diese truppe haben wir
verloren das muss mal vorstellen also ja
haben sie völlig recht immer anders
haben können aber übrigens ich ja
[Gelächter]
gegen diese truppe haben wir verloren im
letzten bundestagswahlkampf sind wir
sehenden auges in eine niederlage
reingelaufen viele haben im vorfeld auch
davor gewarnt jetzt ist es aber so dass
auch eine andere regierung dran ist und
ich erwarte dann aber auch von so einer
regierung dass sie eine mehrheit in so
einer zentralen frage hat also man kann
ja bei der impfpflicht dafür oder
dagegen sein aber ich erwarte von einer
bundesregierung dass sie eine mehrheit
hat und die hat sie offensichtlich nicht
und versucht jetzt über verfahrens
tricks jetzt irgendwie doch was
hinzukriegen nur damit der liebe
gesundheitsminister und der
bundeskanzler dann ihr gesicht wahren
können ja beenden wir mal diese
therapiesitzung der union nach beweisen
kann man kann man wieder zum thema also
die österreicher haben wir die
impfpflicht eingeführt gegen massive
widerstände ich war auch jemand den man
sich davor gewarnt hat und das war ein
mega desaster mittlerweile ist die
ausgesetzte für drei monate warum weil
sie nicht verfassungskonform ist weil
sich niemand überlebt hat wer
kontrolliert das wie kontrolliert muss
wie schafft man das dass die menschen
nicht aus dem arbeitsprozess rausfallen
und wie können kann man argumentieren
weil es geht ja um die
verhältnismäßigkeit einer impfpflicht
bei ebola werden wir uns alle einigen
wird so sein aber bei etwas harmloser
ist mittlerweile bei um bekommen die wie
eine grippe ist die verhältnismäßigkeit
der nicht gegeben und im grunde immer
wer rettet uns denn von uns bürger denn
vor den parteien und vor dem zwang die
zwang der ahnungslosen unter der
hoffnungslosen aber diese regierungen
vermitteln europaweit mittlerweile
gerade deutschland und österreich sind
eine große vorbilder haben ganz europa
lacht ja mittlerweile über german angst
german austrian angst nur wer will wir
fürchten uns zu tode vor allem geben wir
wollen in vollkasko staat so zu schützen
dann bitte lieber staat beschützt mich
doch vor allem bösen und vergessen dass
eigentlich die stärke unserer
gesellschaft und der freiheit des
einzelnen in der selbstverantwortung
legten noch dazu das muss darf man nicht
vergessen ist ein ungeimpfter gleich
anstecken wie eingeimpft auch für die
für die risikogruppen dem ries dem
ungeimpften der risikogruppen oder dem
geimpften aus der risikogruppe es ist
völlig egal ob er ein ungeimpfter oder
in gamestar in ansteckte sein verlauf
ist da völlig gleiche also wir schießen
mit kanonen auf spatzen und das ist
einfach nur abzulehnen weil es ist
mittlerweile nur mehr eine angst
getriebenen kampagne gesteuert von einer
kleinen minderheit von zeugen corona die
das
mittlerweile zur glaubensfrage erklärt
haben man glaubt ja mittlerweile am
corona es gibt den großen corona alter
die die spritze davor aber dass man mit
logik und vernunft und sich die zahlen
anschaut österreichischen zahlen die
zahlen des rk ii die an
deckungsvarianten die die spitals
belegungen bespricht sie nichts mehr
dafür und bisschen weniger hysterie
bisschen weniger glauben bisschen mehr
aber ein bisschen auch noch mehr unsere
demokratie hoch halten also so zu tun
als ob da zwei drei leute sich selbst an
land haben und gesetze durchprügeln so
ist es weder in österreich noch in
deutschland und die regierungen die
daten wurden ja auch von bürgerinnen und
bürgern gewählt ich sage in unserem fall
in deutschland leider wir hätten es uns
anders gewünscht aber ich sag trotzdem
das ist ja auch eine mehrheit die da ist
und es wusste jeder im wahlkampf was
passieren wird wenn wir nicht mehr den
auftrag zur regierungsbildung gekommen
dass dann eben auch genauso was entsteht
und deswegen würde ich zumindest an dem
punkt widersprechen dass da ja auch eine
mehrheit sich schon gedanken macht und
so zu tun als ob politikerinnen und
politiker das sind der mehrheit nicht
tun kann ich ihnen nur empfehlen
vielleicht auch zu kandidieren nun mal
von innen drin zwischen ja desto
schwächer eine eine demokratisierung der
gesellschaft ist desto mehr regeln
braucht sie denn normalerweise sollte
man als gesellschaft dem ja auch
freiwillig folgen und ich glaube dass
die union als konservative
freiheitspartei die csu als als
klassische freiheitspartei von franz
josef strauß hier wieder wieder
zurückfinden sollte zum
freiheitsgedanken und sich nicht in
linken kollektivismus um zwangssystem
mann verpflichten darum mache ich glaube
man muss noch mal darauf zurückkommen
warum wurde eigentlich die maßnahmen den
letzten zwei jahren eingeführten warum
wurde überhaupt mal begonnen über eine
empfehlung diskutieren
und das war ja die frage der überlastung
des gesundheitssystems diese
voraussetzung ist jetzt offensichtlich
nicht mehr gegeben also ich habe auch
meine auffassung zur impfpflicht
durchaus geändert ich war eben worden
dagegen steht ich werde morgen für den
antrag der unionsfraktionen stimmen der
unter omikron keine impfpflicht vorsieht
der aber die voraussetzung schafft das
sollte sich eine schlimmere variante
wieder ergeben die auf einmal wieder zur
gefährdung das gesundheitssystem sorgen
kann dass diese ihre grund ihre
grundannahme haben sie aber nicht
aufgegeben also bei delta hätten sie
eine impfpflicht durchgesehen auch nur
aufgrund jetzt der omicron variante weil
sie keinen grund für die grund-
argumentationen ist seit zwei jahren wir
wollen im grunde genommen das
gesundheitssystem schützen und das ist
eben nur dann gefährdet wenn dann auch
relativ viele liegen das ist unter
omikron nicht der fall deswegen sage ich
auch jedem das sollte es mal um zu einer
impfpflicht kommen egal wie die aussieht
wird die vom verfassungsgericht
scheitern
weil eben diese voraussetzung dort nicht
mehr eben ist und deswegen finde ich es
ehrlich gesagt auch ziemlich schwierig
was der gesundheitsminister derzeit
macht der ändert nämlich diese
grundbedingung er sagt nämlich nicht
mehr es geht um den schutz des
gesundheitssystems sondern er sagt jetzt
ja wir dürfen doch nicht sehenden auges
dahin laufen dass pro tag 100 200 leute
sterben aber das kann aus meiner sicht
keine begründung personen starken
einkauf sein ich schließe mich erinnern
an aber nur eine kurze frage ist was
sind berechtigt warum sie haben ja den
gesundheitsminister gestellt warum haben
sie denn das gesundheitssystem denn
nicht ausgebaut und corinna fit gemacht
also wir haben das gemacht wir haben
beispielsweise betten haben sie
deutschland geschaffen jetzt will ich
10.000 betten mehr geschaffen wir haben
dafür gesorgt dass jede zusätzliche
pflegekraft die ein krankenhaus
angestellt hat bezahlt worden ist aber
dass wie sie haben ja vorhin schon
selbst erwähnt die wachsen nicht auf den
bäumen ich finde wenn ich mir die
performance von herrn lauterbach
anschauen in vier monaten dann hat es da
jetzt sparen in zwei jahren eigentlich
ganz ordentlich gemacht sie würden jetzt
zurückblickend auf die korona panini
sagen jens spahn war ein guter
gesundheitsminister für deutschland in
so einer situation hat es jeder minister
schwer der da im amt ist aber wenn ich
mir jetzt anschaut dass unter der
harmloseren variante herr lauterbach
nach vier monaten ein block nach dem
anderen schießt und zu großer
verunsicherung führt dann sage ich das
hat er jetzt sparen in zwei jahren
ordentlich gemacht ja in die sonne tief
steht werfen auch die zwerge lange
schatten ja das ist doch ein schönes
schlusswort uns bald kein geißler
bekommen darauf weil sie auch wieder im
soll wird errichtet wo sie also ich habe
mich sehr geärgert muss ich sagen über
unseren bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach tatsächlich was macht denn
dieser mann muss ich mich da fragen am
montag noch sagt er will die korona
quarantäne regelung freiwillig machen
dass man sich kann sie
eigenverantwortlich in quarantäne begibt
wenn man infiziert ist und am dienstag
kommt ihm plötzlich spontan irgendwie
geht ihm ein licht auf und er merkt man
halt moment das sendet irgendwie ein
falsches signal und dann haut er nachts
um 2 uhr 30 das muss man sich mal
vorstellen haut er einen tweet raus wo
er sagt ich habe mich geirrt das ist
falsch das machen wir doch nicht das
wird eher kassieren hat er ein paar
stunden vorher bei markus lanz auch
schon gesagt dass konnte markus lanz ja
augenscheinlich auch schon kaum fassen
was er da was er damit erlebt das kann
nicht wahr sein ein gesundheitsminister
der so sprunghaft addiert ein hin und
her minister ist karl lauterbach
mittlerweile geworden und er hat heute
sogar ganz offen bei einer
pressekonferenz auch noch zugegeben ja
wohl er hat bei twitter auch bei social
media reaktionen bekommen die ihn
bewogen haben dieses verfahren wieder zu
ändern dass er selbst am vortag
eigentlich vorgeschlagen hatte das geht
nicht ein hin und her minister ist eine
realsatire dass er unter anderem
aufgrund von talkshow auftritten und
aufgrund seiner tüte reihe überhaupt
bundesminister geworden ist dass der
jetzt in einer talkshow und bei twitter
dann eine solche eine solche änderung
irgendwie verkündet das kann doch nicht
wahr sein karl lauterbach das ist eines
bundesministers muss ich leider sagen
unwürdig ein solches war ja da kam ich
kann ich ihnen nur anschließen oder karl
lauterbach ist ein schönes beispiel dass
ein klassischer besserwisser wie wir als
kommentatoren sind dann sich zum
notorischen schlechter machen entwickelt
das ist lauterbach hatte eine pleiten
pech und pannen serie die die die
europaweit vielleicht von
österreichische gesundheitsminister noch
erreicht wird aber ansonsten fällt mir
niemand eine solche kleinste abstand
zwischen zwei fettnäpfchen ist
mittlerweile ein lauterbach also wir
müssen man muss anfangen wieder leute
die nicht in jedes mikrofon beißen die
vielleicht vorher mal nachdenken bevor
sie ein interview machen die nicht
süchtig sind mir kommt ja vor die
talkshow winters kokoschka lauterbach
der braucht es für sein ego für seine
präsenz das sind diese kleinen männer
die haben das oft nötig und dias und
klein-klein lage waren nicht so klein
ist ein leben in deinem studie da muss
ich
auch als wäre es nicht so klar er ist
größer als ich ich bin auch große gewalt
die grundgeschichte ist natürlich als
jenige das mikro runter gefallen sind
weitergeben
dann gebe ich euch die frage an frau
werden was herr fuchs natürlich
angesprochen hat ist da
danach twittern ist dieses verhalten
normal so wichtige entscheidungen erst
bei markus lanz darüber zu reden denn um
234 entsteht und dann soll er auch noch
im gesundheitsausschuss gefehlt haben
heute morgen also es ist natürlich
wirklich eine serie die überhaupt nicht
funktioniert und er hat ja auch
anscheinend ein imperatives mandat
dieses imperative mandat wurde eben mal
von den twitter nutzern gegeben
überhaupt gesundheitsminister zu werden
jetzt wenn man mal die reaktionen auf
seine entschuldigung auf twitter
angeschaut hat da es ein spd
bundestagsabgeordneter der twitter dann
ja gut wir hatten die laute
fraktionssitzung hat also was genutzt
sagt einmal geht es eigentlich noch dass
jemand aus der eigenen fraktion ihn dann
auch noch so abschießen öffentlich und
als ich heute früh um sechs aufgestanden
bin und gesehen haben 237 habe ich
wirklich gedacht ist der fake account so
das ist ja wirklich schon ruht das blaue
häkchen da sind weil er wundert sich ja
ob es wirklich war und wenn man dann
weiß woher noch in der talkshow und dann
mein ausschuss war direkt neben
gesundheitsausschuss 1000 kameras
aufgebaut warten auf den
bundesgesundheitsminister und ließ
parallel von den kollegen im
gesundheitsausschuss dass er da nicht
auf tut dann ist es wirklich auch
eintritt in das konto von dem
parlamentarismus von allen kolleginnen
und kollegen weil es so toll ist für ihn
ist mit markus lang zu diskutieren da
hat einfach im ausschuss mit den
kolleginnen und kollegen im bundestag zu
diskutieren und das geht gar nicht und
ich finde man braucht auch sie haben's
grad richtig gesagt mal das nachdenken
man braucht aber auch mal als politiker
ab und zu sein schlaf und ich würde mir
wünschen wenn ein
bundesgesundheitsminister
der so wichtige entscheidungen wo es um
die gesundheit wo es ums leben der
menschen geht dass er das nicht macht
indem er übernächtigt ist übermüdet ist
und dann irgendwann mal was raus haut
das geht einfach nicht er hat ja mit
diesem lesen von studien hat er sich ja
selbst auch irgendwie ins gespräch
gebracht er ist gesundheitsminister dann
heißt es immer ja der liest nacht ganz
akribisch diese ganzen studien ja das
macht er vielleicht auch er ließ da
irgendwie rein aber dann liest er da
irgendwas es schnappt da irgendwas auf
das jagdhaus ich erinnere mich daran wie
ihr irgendwie getwittert hatte vor
einigen monaten da war er noch nicht im
amt als bundesgesundheitsminister ja
kann auch sein dass irgendwie corona
über die klospülung sich ziehen den in
den in den ein also in den
mehrfamilienhäusern sich dann
untereinander inzwischen die wohnung
verteilt solche solche absurditäten das
sind da liest er irgendwas bley ist das
haus denkt nicht darüber nach was das
dann menschen da sehr verunsichert sind
davon er täte gut daran jetzt als
bundesminister da stimme ich völlig zu
muss man sich anders verhalten das geht
so nicht mehr aber war das nicht ein
spannender prozess steininger die frage
an sie ich fand den prozess wie karl
lauterbach gesundheitsminister geworden
ist sehr spannend man kennt es ja aus
den parteien bitte widersprechen wenn
ich jetzt unrecht sage wenn man zum
beispiel in einem kleinen landesverband
ist ist es eigentlich schon mal eher
unwahrscheinlich die große
parteikarriere bis zum minister zu
machen und ihr drei saarländer im
kabinett das war auch ein manchmal gehts
aber es geht nicht immer das ist ja
meistens schon auch parteipolitik oder
würden sie mir da widersprechen der
minister wird also so wie man da steht
in der partei und da fand ich oder
sebastian herrscht da fand ich den weg
von herrn lauterbach spannend als
ausnahme beispiel die partei wollte ihn
eigentlich nicht also die politik wollte
ihn eigentlich nicht und er hat es über
die bürger die ja übrigens karl
lauterbach wollten es war also
eigentlich die du warst nicht sogar die
demokratischste minister entscheidung
dass man sich jetzt nicht so genau zum
einstimmen natürlich zu stehlen also
wenn sie eine regierung gebildet wird
ist es bei vielen so dass die dann auf
einmal als wir bekommen weil das fenster
offen war und dann auf den ruf hören
möchte hat einen da ereilt bei manchen
funktioniert dann bei manchen nicht am
schluss muss man sagen karl lauterbach
den wollte eigentlich keiner in der spd
denn ja weder der olaf scholz den wollte
die fraktionsführung nicht und wenn wir
jetzt den europäern eben angesprochen
auch innerhalb von der fraktion hat er
kein gutes standing und was hier
passiert ist ist das über empfunden und
die twitter community so ein großer
öffentlicher druck auf die boj wird das
lauterbach dann minister werden sollte
und ich erinnere mich noch dass kevin
kühnert angesagt hat ihr wolltet ihr
krieg
und so das sagen sie wollten ihn dann
und jetzt kriegen sie auch und was ich
sehr spannend auf twitter finden wo ja
auch sehr viele mit sehr radikalen
positionen unterwegs die sind auf einmal
ganz schön enttäuscht von diesem neuen
gesundheitsminister und das sagt halt
auch viel und das hat ihn ja getrieben
jetzt in der nacht offensichtlich dass
die leute in der reaktionen geschickt
haben mit ihnen ehrlich gerechnet hatte
und dann klickt er davor ein ohne
offensichtlich großen auch ganzen vielen
gelegt linke enttäuschte feministinnen
für die ja wirklich der totale hält auf
twitter war wirklich über monate es war
so ihr gott wenn sie an gebetet haben
und dann hatten sie ihn und jetzt waren
es wirklich total traurige tweets die
größte enttäuschung jedes lebens als ob
es ihr ehemann wer also es war
das war ja schon bezahlt ja schon bei
der bei der bei der abschaffung der
masten fläche eigentlich aber muss schon
sehen also weder olaf scholz hilft ihm
also er könnte ja die seinen richtigen
kompetenz durchsetzen und ihm an der
stelle helfen auch die fdp ein stück war
zwingen noch die spd-fraktion die fdp
will den auch nicht und jetzt auch noch
nicht mal mehr die twitter-community es
wird einsam um karl lauterbach worauf
müssen wir denn jetzt warten oder
nachrichten und der bromacker überhaupt
nicht was ich spanne zu verwerten
anscheinend ist karl lauterbach der
beste mann der cdu in der regierung wenn
man so zuhört also sie können da gibt es
noch
auf die verteidigungsminister
diana garde dieser dieser regierung ist
ist beneidenswert dass der arme urlaub
scholz das kaiser soja wäre vielfach
ermordet worden im alten rom aber aber
die geschichte ist ein lauterbach zeigt
halt dass man wenn man sich nach
stimmungen auf twitter richtet wenn
twitter a sagt muss man als normaler
politiker automatisch bei machen weil
twitter ist immer völlig entfernt von
der normalen volkes meinung also das ist
das der beste indikator die die
links-grüne blase journalisten blase
medien blase auf auf twitter liegt
generell immer falsch wenn verglichen
mit den mehrheitsverhältnissen bei der
bevölkerung bei wahlen das ist einfach
reziprok argumentieren lassen sich
natürlich auch treiben von twitters ich
kann auch nicht immer das gegenteil wahr
das hab ich bei der afg schon gar nicht
immer sagen machen das gegenteil von dem
was die afg gesagt oder so dann ist man
sich treiben von diesen leuten man muss
schon selbst überlegen und selbst die
programmatik entwickeln und nicht nur
irgendwie hauptsache dagegen egal ob
jetzt gegen twitter oder gegen die afg
zum beispiel dass das ist mir dann auch
so einfach an der stelle ja aber das
stimmt ja völlig aber das ist ja nur ein
indikator bei den geschichten also dass
das ist wenn man wenn man bürgerlich
mitte rechts ist dann weiß man natürlich
keine rot-grünen meinungen in vielen
dingen dass das ist ja das ist ja eine
logik
ja bei den grünen also gott behüte also
von dem her ich war noch kärnten einen
diesel und möchte ich möchte auch noch
meine kinder gut ausgebildet haben und
möchte meine kultur weiter leben dürfen
und nicht grün
ich hoffe ich werde im ganzen privat
also solange ich meinen gesunden
menschenverstand und hausverstand noch
das darf man ja heutzutage nicht mehr
sagen hausverstand diese abgeschafft
weil wir sind ja die gender die sinne
wir sind ja politisch korrekt und wir
dürfen ja heutzutage nicht mehr sagen
was vor 20 jahren war völlig normal war
war ohne und dafür geprügelt zu wären
natürlich kann man sagen aber man hat
natürlich massive nachteile ich habe so
ein beispiel zu nennen eigentlich also
hier dürfen sie alles sagen das reicht
der freiheit also was weiter passiert
ist kann ich natürlich auch völlig egal
ich vertrete meine
meinung ich sage zum beispiel klassische
beispiel migration dass zum beispiel wir
haben in wien bezirken mit über 90%
pflichtschulbereich nichtdeutsche
muttersprache
das hätte man vor 20 jahren noch locker
sagen können das ist nicht gut das geht
nicht der integration dass das sie
kreiert die die deutschsprachigen kinder
das wird aus dem kommt nichts gutes wenn
man das heute sagt dass man
ausländerfeind dann ist man gegen
integration dann ist man gegen
multikulti und man dies gegen dieses
dieses diese neue wunderbare punkt hat
die aber leider dann eine jahre
änderungen wenn es in wien 25 prozent
aller jugendlichen in der
mindestsicherung sind während
gleichzeitig die betriebe händeringend
arbeitskräfte suchen zu dem thema ich
möchte jetzt nicht das wort auch schon
aber zum thema flüchtlinge kommen wer
noch nach der werbung reicht aber noch
kurz vor der unterbrechung frau
beherrscht einer von ihnen beiden ein
kurzes fazit wenn man jetzt als bürger
darauf warten sollte das kalbach
zurücktreten muss wie viel muss denn
noch passieren dass im bereich des
möglichen liegt fangen sie gerne an und
deinen folgen die frau wäre vielleicht
mit situations fehler in irgendeiner
seiner habilitationsschriften oder
ähnliches glaube ich allerdings nicht
ich denke nicht dass er zurücktreten
wird in den nächsten wochen aber es ist
schon ziemlich ernst weil er nämlich die
bevölkerung verunsichert durch solche
aktionen und das liegt mir vor allen
dingen am herzen dass wir dafür nicht
sorgen und mir wäre es tatsächlich
wichtig dass er häufiger im
gesundheitsausschuss als bei markus lanz
ist ich glaube das hat das land dient so
eine ganz andere ernsthaftigkeit ich
glaube dass er völlig überfordert ist
dass er das sich ganz anders vorgestellt
hat und es ist eben was anderes auch mit
also es ja auch für die ganzen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
zuständig ist ja auch chef von diesen
behörden das darf man auch nicht
unterschätzen und wenn ich jetzt da
beamtin im gesundheitsministerium wer
würde ich mich auch ärgern dass ich mir
den ganzen tag hier den hintern aufreißt
und arbeite und mein chef hat und nur in
talkshows herum also deswegen bitte
wieder nächste sitzungswoche am mittwoch
gesundheitsausschuss pullover haus da
wird da dringender gebraucht den appell
geben wir hier mit einem car lauterbach
weiter und wir sind nach einer ganz
kurzen unterbrechung zurück bleiben sie
dran es wird sehr spannend werden mit
den zwei letzten themen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück meine damen
und herren bei viertel nach acht ich
würde jetzt gerne für ein kurzes update
was wir immer machen
zyperns heime nach abschalten ob er
schon da ist bislang sehe ich ihn noch
nicht dann probiert es nochmals zu einem
späteren zeitpunkt und wir machen
erstmal weiter mit auch in den abfall
der bist du sehr gut dauert ja immer ein
bisschen bis sich die leitung dann auch
aufbaut genau du bist live zugeschaltet
einer der letzten journalisten die in
kiew sind und meine frage ist natürlich
an dich ehrlich gesagt jeden tag
dieselbe wie ist es vor ort kannst du
uns um den finger acht zuschauern ein
update geben
ja vielleicht erst einmal lena ich bin
nicht mehr einer der letzten sondern es
kommen immer mehr journalisten die jetzt
wieder hier nach kiew dennis wird
sicherer den kiew wir es nicht mehr in
der gefahr eingekesselt zu werden
momentan zumindest es gibt wenig
raketenalarm wenig sie reden land alarm
nur noch es gibt theoretisch die
möglichkeit natürlich weiterhin hier
auch einzuschießen deswegen ist das
jetzt nicht völlig risikolos aber es hat
nichts mehr mit dem zu tun was es in den
vergangenen sechs wochen des krieges war
unabhängig davon wird der horror des
krieges und das was die russischen
truppen angerichtet haben immer klarer
in borodjanka die beiden städte
vollkommen zerstört und es gibt immer
neue horror berichte von dort
über erschießung berichte über
vergewaltigungen
berichte über kriegsverbrechen und das
ist auch das was momentan hier die
debatte natürlich im politischen kiew in
der ukraine
bestimmt und der schock ist immer noch
groß ich komme gerade von vitali
klitschko wladimir klitschko die mit dem
ich dort am sonntag in bucha war und
witali sagte zu mir ich werde nie mehr
vergessen was ich dort gesehen habe die
leichen auf den straßen ich habe
alpträume gehabt davon das ist das was
mir kiels bürgermeister erzählt und
gleichzeitig gibt es eine große sorge
was den osten des landes angeht also die
gefahr die für kiew bestanden hat vor
sechs wochen nämlich eingekesselt zu
werden als geheimdienste gesagt haben
innerhalb von stunden könnte hier die
stadt fallen lässt war der grund warum
so viele menschen die geflüchtet sind
warum es so viele journalisten damals
raus sind weil man sorge hatte jetzt
kommen die russischen soldaten jetzt
wird es passieren konnte sich
verteidigen und die große frage ist kann
dass der osten auch können dass städte
wie die pro können dass städte wie hp
können dass der dom das und die große
sorge ist dass die russische armee weil
sie hier zurück geschlagen wurde jetzt
mit noch mehr wucht dort den dom was ein
fesseln könnte bei eines will und kann
wladimir putin nicht mit einer komplett
niederlage diesen krieg abbrechen
deswegen sagt die ukraine schickt uns
bitte endlich und schnell mehr waffen es
geht hier um jede stunde
golfino herzlichen dank für dein update
wir werden uns morgen abend wieder hören
ich bin sehr froh ehrlich gesagt dass es
sicherer ist in kiew dementsprechend ja
auch für dich und für die bevölkerung in
kiew und ich wünsche dir noch einen
schönen abend hat sich blöd an wir
machen jetzt hier weiter danke dir
und damit frau bär ist ja auch viele
menschen paulas eben schon angefangen
geflüchtet und das ist ja ein thema das
sie bewegt und worüber sie heute
sprechen möchten genau das liegt uns
natürlich insgesamt als cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion aber auch mir ganz
besonders als stellvertreterin von
friedrich merz die zuständig ist für die
frauen für die kinder die zu uns kommen
sie am herzen und was wirklich skandalös
ist ist dass wir eine
bundesfamilienministerin haben die jetzt
heute nach 120 tagen wo die regierung im
amt ist das erste mal inhaltlich im
ausschuss war sie war einmal anfang des
jahres da durfte man keine inhaltlichen
fragen stellen das war eine reine
vorstellungsrunden und heute ging es
dann um themen die meines erachtens in
manchen bereichen themen waren jetzt
vielleicht nicht die mehrheit der
bevölkerung betreffen und als es dann um
die fragestellungen ging wie gehen wir
mit den geflüchteten frauen mit den
geflüchteten kindern um war dann ganz
viel lehrstelle wir haben ja auch die
forderungen dass zum beispiel
schutzzonen an unseren bahnhöfen
eingerichtet werden dass sich die frauen
und die kinder die jugendlichen bei uns
wohlfühlen können fehlanzeige und was
besonders schmerzt ist dass das
offensichtlich auch so eine
wurschtigkeit und auch meines erachtens
11 nehmen des themas ist nicht nur bei
der bundesfamilienministerin
sondern auch bei der
bundesverteidigungsminister rinn bei der
bundes innenministerin da ist eine ganz
ganz große leerstelle und deswegen sage
ich an dieser stelle olaf scholz muss
jetzt endlich mal dass seine arbeit
machen wir brauchen einen krisenstab der
den namen auch verdient würde mir auch
wünschen er würde ein ukraine kabinett
einrichten wir haben das in der letzten
regierung zu ganz vielen themen gehabt
wir hatten ein permanent tagen das
digital kabinett wir hatten aber auch
ein brett kabinett wir hatten aber auch
zum beispiel ein klima kabinett auf
wunsch auch der spd und jetzt gibt es
aber kein ukraine kabinett obwohl man
eigentlich erwarten müsste das 24 7 alle
an einem tisch sitzen die katastrophen
dienste aber auch mit den ländern
regelmäßig gesprochen wird und ich habe
vor ein paar wochen im ausschuss mal die
staatssekretärin weil wie gesagt die
ministerin nicht angewiesen ist gefragt
ob denn das bundesfamilienministerium
ministerium eingebunden es in so einen
krisenstab da hieß es sie telefoniert
mit den länderkollegen einmal die woche
und da muss ich ganz offen sagen dass es
so wenig und die frauen und die kinder
die zu uns kommen haben jeden schutz
verdient und der ist meines erachtens
nicht ausreichend gegeben
frau wer sie haben gerade angesprochen
dass mehr passieren muss ich habe das
gefühl dass ich vor allem die kommunen
auch alleine gelassen fühlen wo er dann
auch die geflüchteten hinkommen was
könnte man dagegen tun oder möchten sie
vielleicht mal erklären wie das auch in
deutschland abläuft für den zuschauer na
ja es ist so dass wir natürlich die
arbeit bei den kommunen lassen und man
muss an der stelle auch mal den ganzen
ehrenamtlichen wirklich danken die da
eine ganz ganz große willkommenskultur
haben es ist in jeder das wetter zu
bestätigen unseren kommunen das sind
schulen die sind voll mit den
geflüchteten frauen und kindern das sind
fast alle gemeindesäle die bürgermeister
vor ort die landräte die da ihre arbeit
machen und jetzt geht es natürlich darum
wie können sie jetzt auch eine
integration eine beschulung eine
pädagogik mitbringen für die kinder die
zu uns kommen wir hatten heute gemeinsam
mit friedrich merz auch aus angeles und
auch eine ehemalige parlamentarierin aus
der ukraine ukraine bei uns im deutschen
bundestag die er nach warschau
geflüchtet sind um von polen aus eben
ihrem land zu helfen und die haben auch
darum gebeten dass vor allem die kinder
jetzt schnell in die kindergärten kommen
in die kitas kommen in die schulen
kommen aber natürlich auch behutsam das
muss natürlich auch so ein stufenplan
sein dass sie auch erst mal ihre
traumata in den griff bekommen also wir
haben unseren die frauen erzählt dass
selbst die zweijährigen kinder die jetzt
nicht direkt beschossen wurden aber nur
alleine von den sirenen so traumatisiert
sind die sie da auch über wochen oder
über tage und wochen mitbekommen haben
und die kommunen brauchen da einfach
auch bundesweit mal einen plan bis
funktionieren soll sollen sie jetzt
gleich dann auch schon die deutsche
sprache mit erlernen sollen sie
gleichzeitig aber noch die idee in den
schulen sind auch in der ukraine
zugeschaltet werden da klappt das ja
ganz gut mit der digitalen bildung wie
sie zugeschaltet werden weil sie halt
auch sagen dass über 72 prozent ihrer
landsleute stand jetzt auch wieder
zurück wollen die wollen auch ihr land
wieder aufbauen und das was sie
angesprochen haben oder was hier auch
genannt wurde von in dem film war auch
der große wunsch der frauen das einfach
mehr waffenlieferungen stattfinden dass
sie sich selber verteidigen dürfen dass
sie ihr land auch wieder aufbauen dürfen
und dass sie aber jetzt natürlich
möchten dass auch die frauen und die
kinder auch registriert werden dass es
auch ganz wichtig weil wir wissen ja
auch gar nicht wie viele im land sind
auch diese registrierung verweigert
die ampel an der stelle die
bundesinnenminister den sagt jammer kann
die gar nicht registrieren weil die
sollen ja auch nicht verlieren dann
irgendwer grenze stehen komischerweise
schaffen es die polen wesentlich besser
an ihrer grenze sich da zu kümmern und
das ist meines erachtens ein
armutszeugnis und könnte wesentlich
besser gelöst aber ist es nicht ganz an
beginn ist übrigens zu genießen
vielleicht sollten wir das öfter machen
2 von ähnlichen partei muss ja nicht
dieselbe partei aber herr steininger
wenn ich das höre die registrierung hat
nicht geklappt da denke ich mir als
bürgerin also 2015 war aber nicht die
aktuelle regierung an der macht haben
das nicht sie nicht hinbekommen also
genau ihre regierung dass im jahr 2015
und auch im jahr 2016 einiges nicht gut
gelaufen ist war klar allerdings hat
sich in den letzten jahren ja auch dann
viel getan und es geht ja jetzt nicht
nur um die frage diejenigen zu schützen
also die jetzt zu uns kommen sondern das
war ja auch die diskussion über die
frage müssen wenn ich eigentlich auch
die registrieren die hier hilfe
angeboten haben in den ersten wochen und
wo wir wissen das natürlich ganz ganz
viele mit bunten motiven gekommen sind
aber eben auch zuhälter hier aus berlin
am berliner hauptbahnhof gestanden haben
und gesagt haben
frauen und kinder wir nehmen euch auf
das etwas was ich ganz ganz ganz
furchtbar finde und dass wir es da nicht
geschafft haben zu einer regelung zu
kommen ist fatal denn das hätten sie
geschafft also die union hätte das
geschafft da bin ich mir sicher weil aus
den erfahrungen die wir jetzt 15 16
gemacht haben wir in den folgejahren
genau dies dann auch passiert ist was
mir aber noch mal wichtig ist ist dass
wir die kommunen besser unterstützen
weil wenn man sich die flüchtlingszahlen
auch der des letzten jahres angeschaut
haben dann waren die ja nicht bei null
auch im jahr 20 21 kamen menschen zu uns
auch da war der wohnraum in meiner
region beispielsweise schon knapp jetzt
kommen über ganz kurze zeit noch mehr
menschen hinzu vor ort redet man man
bestellt container und anderes viel
privater wohnraum wird auch freigegeben
aber hier brauchst eine
gesamtstrategie auch des bundes dass wir
die kommunen besser unterstützen wir
haben jetzt zum beispiel schon wenn ich
das noch ergänzen darf zu wenig
kindergartenplätze in vielen bereichen
und jetzt weiß man dass noch viel viel
mehr kinder dazukommen
der plan ist zwar da das hat die ampel
heute auch noch mal bestätigt ja wir
wollen das aber es ist jetzt im haushalt
nirgendwo haushalterisch hinterlegt und
genau so wie wir es von beiden
pflegerinnen und bei den pflegern
besprochen haben wachsen ja auch
diejenigen die im kindergarten arbeiten
nicht auf den bäumen also da gute
erzieherinnen so bekommen das sind in
der regel ja auch frauen
die übrigens nicht ganz ganz lange
ausbildung machen auch mit fünf jahren
das ist ja auch nicht von ungefähr und
die plätze braucht man aber jetzt da
muss man dann auch kreativer unterwegs
sein und die jetzt schon sagte mit
einführen und sie wie gesagt dann auch
zur versuchung werde klären ich hoffe du
nimmst mich übrig für die gern noch mal
bei der registrierung der flüchtlinge
reiben weil da finde ich ganz spannend
dass ausgerechnet cdu csu und cdu das
heute anbringen sebastian als
politikredakteur vom bild wie hast du
das beobachtet auch in den letzten
jahren mit der registrierung von
flüchtlingen ist es ein neues ampel
problem also wir müssen ja ganz nüchtern
konstatieren dass 2015 folgende aufgrund
des nicht handelns der bundesregierung
da sehe ich frau merkel damals in der
verantwortung sich aber auch ihren
parteikollegen herrn seehofer in der
verantwortung die beiden haben sich dass
intern behagt richtig bei rausgekommen
es auch nichts dass wir einen massiven
zuzug hatten auch von menschen die
tatsächlich eben keine flüchtlinge waren
und die gelegenheit genutzt haben hier
ins land zu kommen und da ist viel zu
lange nichts gemacht worden und wenn
jetzt frau feser die jetzige in
ministerin so etwas möglich haben also
wiederholt in dem sie indem sie sich
jetzt gesagt nur ihre registrierung
findet sich nicht in ordnung man muss
doch erst mal alle reihen lassen und so
um sich das wiederholt dann glaube ich
erleben wir dass wir schon wieder
riskieren dass die hilfsbereitschaft
dann sehr schnell ans ende kommt und ich
glaube auch tatsächlich es ist noch
nicht erkannt wort mit welcher dimension
wie es hier zu tun haben wir ja
millionen ukrainer frauen und kinder vor
allem auf der flucht sind und das wird
uns noch gesellschaftlich der
unglaubliche anstrengung und
unglaubliche leistung abverlangen diese
situation dem kann ich mich nur
anschließen man darf nicht vergessen all
seinen deutschen und hat 2015 über eine
million flüchtlinge aufgenommen ganz
europa ist dieser furchtbare satz von
angela merkel im kopf mit wir schaffen
das die selbst lieder noch mehr werden
wie die motten das licht angezogen haben
und den sie flüchtlingsströmen noch mehr
belebt haben und damals darf nicht
vergessen sind ja hauptsächlich entgegen
allen erzählungen damals hauptsächlich
junge männer gekommen über 80 prozent
waren waren junge männer aus überwiegend
islamischen ländern jetzt muss man sagen
kommen ja aus der ukraine kommen ja
christliche frau mit kindern das ist ja
ein anderes integrationsproblem sondern
da sind erstens unsere nachbarn müssen
ja nicht die ganze welt retten aber wenn
wir sagen immer hilfe vor ort immer
predigen mann soll vor ort helfen dann
sind wir natürlich in der in der in der
lage und sind auch gefordert in unsere
hintern zu helfen und ich finde das
schon ab wie sie verzeihen sie mir ein
land wie deutschland wie viele einwohner
sind über 80 millionen oder diskutiert
über die probleme 300.000 ukrainische
frauen und kinder aufnehmen zu können
und zwar genau diejenigen leute die 2015
kommt die über eine million
islamistischen männer schaffen wir also
da muss man schließen dass auch in
zeiten einer haupteingang ist das beste
zeugnis tisch das würde ich in japan
kann so ausschauen allein die ersten
drei monate das sie dass dieses jahres
ist ja der flüchtlingsstrom um 89
prozent in der ju gestiegen das sind die
neuen zahlen der union und die die
ausgenommen der ukraine ist die stärkste
gruppe sind 130.000 afghanen nach europa
gekommen in den ersten drei monaten das
sehen die zahlen und es gibt halt
mittlerweile auch und ich sage das jetzt
überspitzt sehr viele
ukraine anscheinend wenn man sich auch
den bahnhöfen bin ich darauf machen dass
sie kein kind von meinungen aber dann
ist
ihre zeit ist was wir müssen
also eines dazu sage wie sie denn die
tausenden flüchtlinge die bieten
lukaschenko an wer weiß wo sie
spanischen grenze gehabt sind die noch
an der grenze oder sind die mittlerweile
schon in polen über den umweg der
ukraine sind mittlerweile in deutschland
wo sind denn die kein mensch mehr von
den großen von flüchtlingsstrom über die
über weißrussland
das sind dinge die man könnte man
vielleicht nachfragen und das ist dann
man will ja niemanden was man bestellt
aber warum gerade rot grün nicht für die
registrierung ist von flüchtlingen muss
man muss rot-grün erklären da muss man
sich nicht wundern ich finde aber den
satz wir schaffen das von merkel die
finde ich nicht schlimm ich finde ich
finde ich schlimm haben wir uns freuen
verlusts zugelassen habe das war der
fehler nicht dass wir sagen wir schaffen
es tatsächlich
geschafft wieder in ganz europa gut aber
es kann immer gern einmal schon in der
ein falscher zungenschlag rein und
nämlich dass wir problematisieren dass
wir hier jungen frauen helfen und
kindern helfen das ist ja gerade nicht
der fall aber wir wissen dass wenn viele
menschen zu uns kommen das ist folge
probleme gibt und die müssen eben
frühzeitig gelöst und zum thema
registrierungs gab diese woche im
gespräch mit der bundespolizei die
bestätigen dass es funktionieren würde
also da ist in den letzten jahren dann
auch einiges nachgeholt worden wir haben
auf jeden fall gesehen dass das thema
großen redebedarf hatte ich glaube das
werden wir noch öfter bei 48 haben und
damit deswegen habe ich sie geradezu
rüde unterbrochen damit sie genug zeit
auch für ihr thema noch haben
aber damit haufen gemacht
nein aber grundsätzlich geht es darum
frank walter steinmeier deutschland
präsent hat sich diese woche
entschuldigt für die falsche russland
politik der letzten zwei jahrzehnte
putin hat er 2000 russland übernommen
und damals wurde auch mit put in einem
anderen putin versucht eine friedliche
koexistenz eine wirtschaftliche
koexistenz ein miteinander zu schaffen
eine lehre aus dem kalten krieg das
hochwasser getrennt hatte ich komme
selber aus österreich wie waren
aneinander am eisernen vorhang berlin
war eine getrennte statt und wir müssen
uns jetzt einfach anschauen wo wir schon
etwas entschuldigen dass man es versucht
hat man müsste sich dafür entschuldigen
dass man es nicht versucht hat man
sollte sich vielmehr sollte sich europas
politik das sind alle regierungen
gefragt dafür entschuldigen dass wir es
nicht geschafft haben in einem falschen
globalisierungsfonds energieautark zu
machen dass wir rechtzeitig in der
energiewende gebaut haben dass wir alle
unsere armee abgebaut haben ich finde es
sehr spannend dass diejenigen die bisher
gegen die wehrpflicht waren die gegen
die bundeswehr waren die gegen die
aufrüstung waren diejenigen die tram
belächelt haben wo er die nato staaten
gezwungen hat zwingen wollte aufzurüsten
endlich einmal die verpflichtungen zu
nehmen diejenigen die dafür waren krieg
mit wattebällchen zu führen und so
können wir haben kann konventionellen
kriegen wir in europa dass diejenigen
die größten kriegstreiber und und
drucken und waffen in die ukraine
schränken wollen sondern europa hängt
mittlerweile am schuss der amerikaner
joe biden und wenn man sieht dass zum
beispiel der frühere pazifist habeck die
grünen haben ja wahlkampf gemacht noch
gegen waffenlieferungen in
kriegsführende staaten jetzt zum end
unrechts geschrieben nach katar pilgert
und sich dort so tief vor dem scheich
verbeugt der homosexuelle verfolgt der
palästinenser quält und habe ich macht
einen kutter dass man sie hoffen muss
dass dort wahrscheinlich seine füße
gewaschen hat
wir brauchen wieder ein starkes europa
wir brauchen ein starkes europa wir
brauchen ein geeintes europa und wir
brauchen ein aufgerüstetes europa wellen
menschen und machtmensch wird putin
verstehen nur stärker und direktheit
absolute zustimmung beim letzten satz
putin versteht nur stärker aber ich
würde widersprechen bei der these dass
wir es vor einigen jahren mit einem
anderen putin zu tun gehabt haben das
wird uns glaube ich jetzt mittlerweile
klar dass jetzt über sehr lange zeit
dieser krieg auch vorbereitet worden es
ab 2014 begonnen als wir auch nicht
bereit waren als deutschland
entsprechend schärfere sanktionen zu
machen und nach ein paar monaten dann
auch wieder wer hat zum zum daily
business übergegangen sind und von daher
ist eine entschuldigung eines politikers
muss man immer fragen was bringt das am
schluss aber wenn es dazu führt dass wir
uns eingestehen dass wir hier eine
falsche politik gemacht habe dann finde
ich das richtig und wenn es dann
insbesondere einer derjenigen macht die
ja zu dieser russland connection der spd
dazu gehören wie schröder schwesig und
andere klingbeil dann fand ich das
zumindest gut dass das passiert ist also
ich halte es für freistaat
parteipolitisches kleingeld zu wechseln
auf unsere konservative österreichische
bundeskanzler schüssel weilen in
aufsichtsräten sowie auch zwei
sozialdemokratische bundeskanzler
punkten hat die die alte die
abgehalfterten alt politiker europas
gesammelt wie andere briefmarken und
sich aber auch jetzt gemerkt dass ihnen
das auch nichts bringt er hat einfach
man kann dazu stehen wie man will man
kann sagen die nato hat sich erweitert
gegen ihr ging entgegen dem versprechen
die man russland gegeben hat russland
hat die ukraine ihr
können diskutieren das sind ja neue
dokumente einmal ganz kurz sebastian
geist schon reingehen weil mit der
nato-erweiterung da gibt es ja viele
berichte die schon gegen diese russische
propaganda wie viele sagen ja sind ja
eigentlich hatten wir ja der der ukraine
habe russland als die ukraine ihre
atomwaffen aufgegeben hat hat man sowohl
in westrussland sie garantien gegeben
was ist denn daraus geworden ich möchte
das ganze auch etwas grundsätzlich
betrachten da treten also politiker an
und sagen sie möchten gewählt werden in
ein öffentliches amt in unserem staat
für uns alle verantwortung tragen so ja
auch herr steinmeier ja und jetzt
einfach nur und man hat uns wir hängen
nicht nämlich nicht wie einfach nur an
den karner wir hängen jetzt auch am
russen gas warum aufgrund von
politischen entscheidungen die unsere
führung getroffen hat ja also schröder
hat das natürlich ganz massiv forciert
merkel später aber genauso so und jetzt
haben wir den laden hier quasi vor die
wand gefahren jetzt haben wir auch eine
situation wie sie jetzt in der ukraine
ist haben wir dazu beigetragen
da muss man sagen das ist ein kiewer ein
grund sich zum einen zu entschuldigen
sondern so etwas da sind andere schon
für sehr viel weniger zurückgetreten
sogar insofern also absolut korrekt und
gewährt gefunden ein rücktritt sei der
einzige ausweg aus menschenrettung in
formen qatargas wo man nur die kleine
kette zu sagen muss dass weder die
katari die die kompetenz haben und die
das volumen dieses gas zu liefern erst
ab 20 24 die anlage so gebaut haben oder
die klitzekleine kleinigkeit dass
deutschland als ein flüssiggas aufnimmt
keinen einzigen flüssiggas terminal hat
und wenn man am flughafen berlin sid wie
unser tester fabriken
hätten sie es jetzt besser gefunden wenn
herr steinmeier zurückgetreten ist
empfinden sie vielleicht auch einfach
die entschuldigung als na ja wozu ich
hätte mich nicht entschuldigt weil ich
glaube das ist damals richtig war ich
glaube dass putin sich in den letzten
fünf jahren zudem entwickelt hat langsam
aber doch was er jetzt ist ein die eine
militärdiktatur dass das muss man ganz
nicht ganz ganz eingestehen also ich
habe mit putin vor ungefähr 15 jahren
mal abend gegessen und da war er
von einer konversation sehr angenehm
sehr klug sehr sehr analytisch sehr
vernünftig denkender mensch man kann
niemanden hinein sind auch wir alle
wissen jetzt nicht ob putin wie viele
vermuten durchgeknallt ist aber einfach
knallhart ist
gegen wladimir putin funktioniert bei
keinen fall nur sie können alle nur
raten sondern eines das umfeld weiß es
ja nicht dass wurde er auch anscheinend
ausgetauscht aber jetzt sitzen wir halt
auf der gasleitung und es kann keine
lösung sein wenn steiner sagt zum
beispiel nach dem 2 dass wir noch dass
wir jetzt eine leitung haben durch die
ukraine kriegsgebiet und sagen nein
damit wir uns jedoch
eine frage an frau berge und zwar hatte
er überstürzt gerade gesagt
militärdiktator putin wie putin ist
hätte steinmeier sich entschuldigen
müssen ja oder nein na ja also ich
wundere mich dass so dass dieses wedding
dass es wirklich ein kriegsverbrecher
ist dass das meines erachtens können
sicher sagen parteipolitik hin oder her
aber dass es von uns nur so deutlich
angesprochen wird und dass es trotzdem
auch bei der spitze der spd und auch bei
vielen in der spd da ist sich immer so
nebulös herum geschmuggelt wird weil man
immer noch eine beißhemmung hat
diesbezüglich und was in dem
zusammenhang auch nicht geht ist dass
jemand wie gerhard schröder immer noch
von uns alimentiert wird das geht
einfach nicht da muss man ganz klar
sagen da muss die spd eine reißleine
ziehen sein absolutes no go das
verhalten nicht nur die maria mutter
gottes hände von seiner ehefrau also
eine farce die da stattfindet sondern er
bekommt geld von den deutschen
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahlern und
die spd zieht keine reis landes damit
irgendwie hat schultertasche aus dem
fanshop entfernt das reicht aber nicht
unter erwarte ich einfach von einer
partei die die bundeskanzler stellt auch
eine komplette distanzierung vom
altkanzler für den man sich wirklich
jeden tag stemmen muss aber das ist nur
eines noch in der geschichte das ist ja
alles schön und schröder war schröder
ist dagegen es geht darum
töten wir mit den sanktionen durch das
gaben die rheingas in bargum machen
töten die unsere industrie frieren wir
und was kommt danach lassen wir aus dem
dritten weltkrieg erschienen ich glaube
weiß daher schröder das aller geringste
problem das wir alle haben unter
schröder wird sich das mit seinem konto
sondern genießen aber wenn sie das
selbst einfach mal so man sich dann
dafür nicht entschuldigen das verstehe
ich sehe mir auch gesagt er hat einen
anderen putin kennengelernt oder gedacht
oder er hat ihn für anders gehalten aber
jetzt sind sie eigentlich selber der
meinung okay der mann wurde unterschätzt
warum darf man sich nicht dafür
entschuldigen das ist eine ganz gute
frage stimmt vielleicht hat sich positiv
verändert wer weiß das boot im jahr
veranstaltet absoluten im jahr 2009
steinmeier hat sich für das entschuldigt
was meiner meinung nach zu dieser zeit
richtig war man hat versucht man musste
die koexistenz mit mit russland suchen
weil russland ist ein gewaltiges land
ist ein wichtiger wirtschaftspartner und
es ist immer besser jemanden zu umarmen
als das in der selber wie lange sind wir
beim ende angekommen heute kann man
russland nicht mehr umarmen da sind wir
alle einer meinung und wir wünschen
ihnen noch einen schönen abend und bis
morgen abend 20 15
[Musik]